[Musique]
bonsoir mardi 25 février bienvenue dans
le journal sur tv 60,18 voici les titres
de l'actualité locale
elles oeuvrent tout au long de l'année
au service de la population par le biais
de ses bénévoles la protection civile
est une association reconnue d'utilité
publique dimanche une journée mondiale
lui est consacré un stand spécifique
sera proposé à poissy et j -19 avant le
premier tour des élections municipales
la campagne se poursuit dans les
yvelines le reportage dans cette édition
à guyancourt avec le candidat à grégory
pape et lors d'une réunion publique à
villepreux donné par jean baptiste à
monique enfin la suite de notre dossier
de la rédaction sur les femmes qui ont
marqué le territoire des yvelines zoom
ce soir sur l'aviatrice hélène boucher
son destin est lié tragiquement à celui
du département en 1934 son appareil
s'est crashé à voisins le bretonneux
dans un instant nous parlerons également
du lien inter générationnel avec une
association qui oeuvre dans les yvelines
c'est habitat et humanisme les depuis
novembre il peut accueillir jusqu'à 100
résidents à buc l'ehpad pierre bienvenu
nouaille a été inauguré officiellement
ce matin l'établissement prend en charge
les pathologies physiques et cognitives
des personnes âgées accueillies il est
géré par l'association chemins
d'espérance qui accompagne les personnes
touchées par la vulnérabilité du grand
âge un montant de l'équipement 9,26
millions d'euros financés à plus d'un
million d'euros par le département des
yvelines
l'ehpad remplace celui situé auparavant
à versailles les propos recueillis par
patrick jacques de dixmude
nous avions un établissement sur
versailles d'une
de 60 président qui n'était plus aux
normes
non mais ehpad donc ce projet nous a
permis
peut-être aux normes avec un bel
environnement et d'accueillir dans une
centaine de résidents et pour les
personnes âgées d'autres solutions
existent au delà de ces résidences
médicalisées
elle prône notamment le lien
intergénérationnel nous avons choisi de
parler de cette thématique à la proche
de la fête des grands-mères qui est ce
dimanche 1er mars et on le fait avec
dominique bruyant des on soit en soins
vous êtes le responsable de l'antenne
versailles grand parc de l'association
habitat et humanisme cette association
agit en faveur du logement et de
l'insertion et de l'art etc la re
création des liens sociaux l'objectif
c'est de lutter finalement contre
l'exclusion et l'isolément des personnes
en difficulté c'est ça oui tout à fait
habitat et humanisme et est depuis et
est un mouvement qui a été créée il ya
35 ans par bernard devert à lyon et qui
a essaimé aujourd'hui elle regroupe
aujourd'hui le mouvement regroupe 55
associations dont habitat humanisme
ile-de-france qui est particulièrement
actif dans le 78 et à versailles pour
accueillir les familles en difficulté et
pour rebâtir du lien social notamment
auprès des seniors nous avons un exemple
qui nous tient à coeur c'est une maison
intergénérationnelle qui a été créé à
jouy en josas en 2016
elle regroupe ce qu'on appelle une
pension de famille avec des personnes
isolées en situation de difficulté mais
aussi des logements familiaux des
familles monoparentales des étudiants et
des familles lambda si je puis dire dans
un bel ensemble de 22 logements
familiaux et 2,26 studio pour la pension
de famille de jouy en josas
et pourquoi justement c'est intéressant
de mélanger finalement différentes
générations au sein d'un même site
qu'est ce que ça peut apporter
finalement de créer ces liens recréer
ces liens intergénérationnels sarr crée
des liens
cet ex nous disent que c'est un le lien
social et notamment pour les seniors est
très important parce que ça les valorise
ses déterminants pour leur santé et
comment dire
c'est une chose qui nous tient à coeur
parce que habitat humanisme ont fait du
logement mais on fait surtout du lien
social et cela veut dire que c'est du
logement accompagner et accompagné
notamment parce que on prévoit des dents
c'est le cas dans la maison
intergénérationnelle de jouy en josas
des locaux communs où on peut se réunir
un jardin partagé et il y à des salariés
qui suivent les personnes mais aussi des
bénévoles qui propose des
accompagnements de collectif peut être
des déjeuners partager des des activités
dans le jardin ou des promenades ou des
sorties
ce que nous recherchons c'est à ce que
les personnes que nous logeons soit
véritablement en lien entre elles autant
qu'elles le souhaitent mais aussi
insérer dans la ville parce que ce
sentiment d'isolement finalement il est
renforcée à cause de la perte
d'autonomie
il doit forcément qu'il y à perte
nous sommes un peu en amont de la perte
d'autonomie est justement est ce que ça
marche la au travers de cet exemple que
vous avez à jouy en josas de recréer ces
liens entre les personnes est ce que
c'est bénéfique pour pour ces personnes
je crois que pour les seniors que nous
avons puisqu'on parle des seniors
aujourd'hui je pense que les seniors que
nous avons actuellement à jouy en josas
on sont très contents d'eux de leur
proximité avec les familles et avec eux
et avec les enfants donc qu'ils sont là
et il s'en félicite mais je précise
qu'il ya trente et une résidence
intergénérationnelle en france 1 qui
sont gérés par habitat et humanisme
il nous en avons encore 15 ans projet
pour 2020
quand il en a en projet une dans les
yvelines par exemple dans les yvelines
pas pour pas pour le moment
pour l'instant mais il y en a en ile de
france
l'association île de france à laquelle
nous appartenons ancrée notamment à
paris très prochainement mais pas pour
pour les yvelines 2 pour l'instant il ya
l'exemple des résidences
intergénérationnelles il y aussi une
autre forme qui est proposé c'est la
colocation intergénérationnelle dans le
cadre d'un oui alors cette colocation
intergénérationnelle nous l'avons
notamment à paris le chabrol et c'est
une expérience qui marche bien depuis
maintenant près de dix ans je crois
alors si on termine cette interview sur
l'implantation d'habitat et humanisme
dans les yvelines alors vous êtes vous
le responsable de l'antenne de
versailles grand parc
est ce que c'est une association qui est
bien implanté sur ce sur ce territoire
quelques exactions vous avez au delà de
ces résidences et versailles grand
intergénérationnel sa masse si je puis
dire nous nous avons des logements
principalement sur versailles viroflay
et jouit en dehors des la maison
intergénérationnelle de jouy dont je
vous ai parlé il y a aussi des petits
collectifs où nous logeons des familles
ce soit à versailles rue édouard charton
ou encore à viroflay avenue moser et
bientôt nous aurons encore un projet
d'un nouveau petit collectif à viroflay
à côté de la gare rive gauche où nous
accueillerons 17 familles est-ce que
vous avez besoin de bénévoles
nous avons besoin de bénévoles ou
l'antenne de versailles grand parc
regroupe aujourd'hui à peu près 80
bénévoles et nous avons et nous aurons
besoin de bénévoles pour remplacer les
bénévoles qui nous partirons normalement
et puis aussi notamment pour le projet
de viroflay où nous allons avoir des
familles qu'il faudra accompagner dans
une période transitoire avant qu'elles
ces familles or recouvre gérer le
logement social traditionnel et toutes
les informations sur habitat et
humanisme a retrouvé sur son site
internet merci dominique bruyant des
aides est repassé en plateau je rappelle
que vous êtes le responsable de
l'antenne versailles grand parc
d'habitat et humanisme
merci petit aparté à présent dans ce
journal avec les élections municipales
premier tour le 15 mars prochain à
villepreux le délégué départemental du
modem jean baptiste à monique conduit
une liste sans étiquette villepreux
naturellement donnait une réunion
publique ce week-end le reportage de
mathilde et demi et de marylène
iapichino une salle pleine pour cette
réunion publique de jean baptiste à
monique le conseiller départemental du
modem présente sa liste sans étiquette
soutenu également par le parti
présidentiel
ses soutiens politiques ce ne sont pas
des soutiens que nous sommes allés
chercher ces des personnes des soutiens
qui se retrouvent dans ce que nous
proposons tant sur le fond que sur la
forme et qui ont décidé de nous apporter
leur soutien à une liste citoyenne et
locales pour élaborer son programme le
collectif a mené une enquête d'octobre à
janvier auprès des habitants
450 personnes ont répondu et parmi les
priorités l'environnement donc là nous
aurons justement d
des mesures fortes je pense notamment un
objectif de zéro artificialisation des
sols que nous inscrirons op élus afin
que nous sanctuariserons nos espaces
naturels et puis nous voudront pousser
la transition écologique local de plus
en plus viennent ensuite la démocratie
de proximité la sécurité et le
développement économique notamment
auprès du commerce local
le commerce local me semble que c'est un
point important dans une ville comme
villepreux
on attend à la fois au niveau central
mais aussi dans les quartiers que des
commerçants qui sont la vie en fait la
vie même d'une dune cités puissent être
dynamique et on est tout à fait prêts à
nous engager pour les aider à 100 il pr
naturellement envisageant travail
rapproché avec la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines sur cette
thématique économique prochaine réunion
publique le 28 février quatre autres
listes sont déclarés dans la commune
la direction guyancourt maintenant où
grégory pape figure parmi les cinq
candidats pour le script de scrutin dans
la ville la semaine dernière celui qui
est soutenu par la république en
marshall est à la rencontre des petits
commerces miquel et demi d'euros environ
et vous comment ça se passe parce que
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
que la mairie actuelle jamais en effet
de quoi vous avez besoin
ce jeudi 20 février grégory pape tête de
liste nouvel élan à guyancourt est parti
à la rencontre des commerces de
proximité du quartier le village l'un
des axes forts de sa campagne
en fait ça s'intègre dans le lieu de vie
dans le vent le lien social
tous les petits commerces font du lien
social ce sont vraiment des lieux de
rencontre vous savez moi je suis
commerçant je suis pharmacien et quand
dans ma pharmacie voix des patients qui
reste discutée qui seront dans ma
pharmacie et demain je suis heureux je
suis heureux parce que ma petite échelle
j'ai réussi à faire du lien social
et ça c'est super important l'occasion
également pour cet épicier installé sur
ce secteur depuis 1997 de partager ces
problèmes des gens parler un peu de
stationnement de voir avec les lieront
surface qui est dans la ville ce qu'ils
ouvrent maintenant tous les dimanches
pendant cette visite pour apporter les
solutions grégory pape et son équipe ont
présenté le dispositif boutic une
interface utilisé à caen reims troyes et
limoges nous leur présentons notamment
une une solution pour la visibilité j'ai
vu que plusieurs villes développe une
application qui permettent de faire la
promotion des commerçants et qui
permettent de le leur faire connaître
ben je trouve que c'est pas mal parce
que du coup ça peut permettre au moment
où c'est quand même d'avoir peut-être un
peu plus de monde et aussi si on peut
faire des réductions des choses comme
nike pour attirer un peu plus de gens au
total grégory pape s'est déjà rendu dans
une cinquantaine de commerces et
continuera à le faire jusqu'au 15 mars
prochain date du premier tour des
élections municipales
je vous rappelle d'ailleurs que dans le
cadre de cette campagne aux élections
municipales tv 78 en association avec
radio sensations vous propose des débats
entre les candidats
ce lundi soir émission consacrée à la
commune de coignières c'est à retrouver
à 20h sur tv 78 ou sur la fréquence 98.4
pour nos confrères de sensations livide
et puis toute l'actualité de ces
élections municipales est à consulter
également chaque mardi soir dans
l'émission 7 8 politique une émission à
retrouver à partir de 18h45 et présenté
par wilfrid richy
[Musique]
une stagnation en 2019 mais pas de quoi
s'inquiéter pour autant le bilan du
tourisme franciliens l'île de france et
le comité régional ont présenté hier les
derniers chiffres du secteur en 2019
35,4 millions d'arrivées hôtelières ont
été enregistrés sur le territoire est
léger recul de 0 1% par rapport à 2018
année record pour le tourisme si la
clientèle internationale est en baisse
celle française a au contraire progressé
plus de plus de quatre cent mille
visiteurs plus de détails sur ces
dernières tendances du tourisme en ile
de france dans notre édition de demain
et mercredi
et vous les avez sans doute déjà croisé
aux abords des monuments ou lors
d'événements dans les yvelines les
bénévoles de la protection civile
reconnaissable avec leurs tenues bleues
et orange une journée mondiale est
consacrée à la protection civile elle se
déroule ce dimanche on en parle avec
aurélien de l'aven
bonsoir êtes le responsable de la
communication pour la protection civile
des yvelines à l'occasion de la journée
mondiale un stand spécifique sera
proposé la place de la république à
poissy on va en parler dans un instant
la protection civile déjà on l'a on la
voit sur le terrain mais qu'est ce que
c'est concrètement la protection civile
et finalement à quelles complémentarités
vous apporter par rapport aux autres
services de secours alors la protection
civile c'est une association agréée de
sécurité civile ce qui signifie que le
rhône et la sécurité les gréements de
sécurité civile est gérée par la
direction générale de sécurité civile et
la gestion de crise ce qui signifie que
c'est le ministère de l'intérieur qui
régit ces règles-là la protection civile
ces trois missions et des formes et se
courir donc on arrive en complément en
complémentarité des services de secours
et en renfort sur certains dispositifs
en complémentarité notamment dans les
dispositifs prévisionnels de secours sur
des événements sportifs culturels ou on
va avoir un poste de secours directement
sur place avec une équipe de secours
prête à intervenir et donc on sera le
premier maillon de la chaîne de secours
et après on pourra effectivement faire
appel à des moyens supplémentaires
notamment samu pompiers
comme on a l'habitude de voir également
mais si on revient sur l'histoire
comment est elle née
justement cette protection civile alors
la protection civile c'est une demande
du général de gaulle à l'époque de sa
présidence qui avait demandé à son
premier ministre georges pompidou de
créer une fédération de protection
civile afin de mettre tous les moyens
dans une fédération voilà pour protéger
les civils
que ce soit en temps de paix en temps de
guerre donc c'est en 1965 qu'elle a été
créée cette fédération est ensuite donc
des associations de protection civile se
sont un peu créé un peu partout en
france et il ya donc une présence de la
protection civile dans les yvelines vous
parliez tout à l'heure des démissions
trois missions principales c'est ça tout
cas vous appliquez aussi sur ce
territoire des yvelines c'est ça comme
partout en france effectivement la
protection civile est représentée
partout en france dans les yvelines où
effectivement nous avons une antenne à
villennes sur seine où effectivement
nous allons proposer des maraudes donc
c'est notre coeur de mission également
donc une fois par semaine nous avons
avoir un équipage qui va à la demande du
samu social sillonné le département pour
apporter que ce soit de la nourriture
des vêtements ou des kits d'hygiène à
des sans-abri
voilà nous allons également avoir une
mission des deux lors de catastrophes
par amp si on reprend les inondations
qui ont touché le département notamment
poissy ces quelques sept dernières
années
on est intervenu plusieurs fois pour
monter des centres d'accueil pour
accueillir effectivement les sinistres
et les accompagner dans cette
douloureuse épreuve est également voilà
les accueillir pour avoir un lit un toit
de quoi manger de quoi se brosser les
dents
ces petites choses on va dire qu'il
semble naturel mais voilà on intervient
pour tout ça en terme sur le département
notre notre plus grande mission c'est le
secours sur le département
donc par la mise en place des
dispositifs prévisionnels de secours ce
qu'on disait tout à l'heure avec
notamment la sollicitation d
des organisateurs d'événements que ce
soit culturelle ou sportive où on va
monter un poste de secours donc une
équipe de secours ça va de 2 à 40
personnes
après de y'a pas des limites selon le
l'événement est donc on sera le premier
maillon de la chaîne de secours en cas
de besoin
l'organisateur peut nous contacter nous
faire intervenir sur le terrain avec du
matériel dédié spécialement secours donc
comme comme les sapeurs pompiers vont
avoir dans leur véhicule on allait le
même matériel est également des
formations qui vont avec tous les
bénévoles qui font des missions de
secours sont formés au ps 20 et pse2
donc c'est du premier secours en équipe
on le rappelle vous êtes il n'y a que
des bénévoles aux siens au sein de la
protection civile
tout à fait il faut le préciser la
protection civile des yvelines c'est 70
bénévoles hommes et femmes à partir de
16 ans qui peuvent être déclenchées à
tout moment dans le département donc
effectivement il n'ya pas de salariés
que des bénévoles mais vous l'avez dit
un volet formation s'est formé aussi
bien les bénévoles mais vous formez
aussi le public aux premiers secours
tout à fait alors on a deux formations
dédiées au grand public
donc on va voir le psc1 premiers secours
civiques de niveau 1 qui est une
formation qu'une formation on va dire
pour apprendre les bases en secourisme
et pouvant intervenir aussi c'est
important en tant que citoyens de
pouvoir intervenir
que ce soit sur un malaise cardiaque sur
une hémorragie et c'est donc on propose
cela effectivement voilà la protection
civile en fait régulièrement à peu près
une fois par mois tous les deux mois et
nos temps de formation est situé à
poissy donc voilà et on a vu alors vous
êtes intervenu notamment on a vu la
corrida de oui c'est des événements de
ce genre sur lesquels vous vous
intervenez dans l'est dans les
alors tout à fait effectivement la
corrida de où il fait partie d'un des
dispositifs prévisionnels de secours
qu'on fait donc on avait effectivement
plusieurs équipes positionnées pour la
corrida de houille
comme vous avez pu le voir je pense dans
les différents reportages qu'on a pu
faire effectivement ça fait partie de
nos missions d'intervenir en
complémentarité des services de secours
voilà dernière chose 1er mars on l'a dit
c'est la journée mondiale de la
protection civile avec une animation qui
sera proposé place de la république à
poissy quel est le programme de la
journée alors c'est la journée mondiale
de la protection civile donc toute la
journée voire plusieurs animations qui
vont avoir lieu notamment une initiation
au massage cardiaque donc ouverte à tous
voilà c'était dur quelques minutes pour
apprendre les bases sur le massage
cardiaque
on va également faire un relais massage
cardiaque donc l'objectif c'est de tenir
de 9h à 17h un massage cardiaque sans de
l'arrêter donc on l'a on a choisi cette
action pour sensibiliser le public à
l'importance des matières un massage
cardiaque le plus longtemps possible
en attendant les secours comme on sait
aujourd'hui que chaque minute compte sur
un arrêt cardiaque voilà il semblait
important pour nous effectivement de
sensibiliser public à ça et à 15 heures
effectivement clôturera la journée par
une démonstration de secours avec une de
nos équipes de secours et notre véhicule
plus d'informations sur cette journée
aussi sur la protection civile des
yvelines sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran merci adrien
de l'aven d'être venu en plateau je
rappelle que vous êtes le responsable
communication de la protection civile
des yvelines la suite de notre dossier
consacré aux femmes qui ont marqué
l'histoire du département à
l'avant-garde de l'aviation au début du
20e siècle hélène boucher était surnommé
leno son destin est lié tristement à
celui des yvelines à 26 ans son chaudron
rafale s'écrase à voisins le bretonneux
après avoir décollé de guyancourt
mathilde demi revient sur son histoire
hélène boucher sur nos mails et nos
jeune femme moderne et avant-gardiste a
marqué tristement les églises en
s'écrasant avec son caudron rafale à
voisins le bretonneux
né en 1908 elle décédera à l'âge de 26
ans à aiguilles en cours
hélène boucher était une jeune fille
tout à fait en jouer
par contre elle savait ce qu'elle
voulait faire puisque elle avait perdu
effectivement un grand ami de son frère
qui est décédé qui était aviateur pilote
d'essai qui était monsieur hubert et
elle a décidé au vu effectué sa dette
aviatrice dans son atelier camille tout
et a choisi de représenter
hélène-boucher enfants suite à une
commande de la ville de
voisins-le-bretonneux la sculpture trône
à l'entrée de la commune à la place de
la piste de l'ancien aérodrome que
l'aviatrice utiliser ce profil
psychologique est assez passionnant et
ça m'a intéressé de de l'encré dans sa
petite enfance mais c'est fictif ce que
vous voyez déjà tout petit c'est calais
c'était une fille déterminée
l'inter qui se cherchait un certain
temps elle est passée par la couture par
les arts plastiques
une jeune femme décrit comme aventurière
et dans la vitesse et l'adrénaline avant
de devenir l'égérie de la marque caudron
renault elle utilisait la moto de son
frère et conduisait la voiture de son
père
chose rare pour l'époque elle boucher
elle se distingue peut-être de tout par
sa modernité
c'est vraiment aujourd'hui ça sera une
jeune fille d'aujourd'hui
en plus c'était une fille énergique
toujours souriante et quant à l'arrivée
chez elle rue de rennes
on savait c'est et l on entend des sons
pas claquer dans la cour et quand elle
monte l'escalier elle le montet 4 à 4
c'était une fille qui était en mouvement
perpétuel
michel c'est niet n'a pas croisé le
chemin de les nommer les deux femmes
sont liés sur leurs formations aériennes
et sur leur combat féministe elle s'est
entraînée à la compétition avec un
moniteur qui s'appelle fred nicole ce
moniteur gelé bien connue parce que il
l'a entraînée en 32 pour les 12 heures
danger pour des compétitions comme ça et
ça a été mon moniteur de de voltige et
puis j'ai aussi très bien connu marcel
richard qui était l'ingénieur découdront
rafale qui lui a donné cette souplesse
si vous voulez
cet accompagnement chez renault que j'ai
connu également hélène boucher devait
représenter son avion doté d'un moteur
renault lors d'une délégation japonaise
le 1er décembre au salon du bourget pour
effectuer un dernier vol d'essai elle
décolle pour la dernière fois de
l'aérodrome de guyancourt le 30 novembre
aux alentours de 15h30 le ciel n'était
pas très beau mais elle a décidé de le
faire quand même
vers 16h30 elle a décidé de reposer son
avion son atterrissage s'est pas bien
passé elle a redécollé et au dernier
virage là où nous sommes aujourd'hui
elle a fait un demi tonneau pour essayer
de se reposer elle a perdu à priori un
peu de puissance elle a remis les gaz
insuffisant et elle s'est plantée à
l'endroit où nous sommes ici elle
décidera dans l'ambulance sur le chemin
de l'hôpital à guyancourt alors accident
à cause de la météo erreur de pilotage
ou problème mécanique
le mystère reste entier elle manqué
d'entraînement sur l'avion
ce que ce sont des avions qui étaient
difficiles et bas comme tous ces avions
qui sont difficiles c'est du
surentraînement surentraînement sens et
là c'est vraiment une faute de pilotage
hélène boucher sera enterré à
ermenonville près de la maison de son
enfance elle recevra la légion d'honneur
à titre posthume est un hommage national
aux invalides une première pour une
femme ou voisins le bretonneux nommera
en hommage à la jeune aviatrice sa rue
principale et son collège
il s'agit bien du corps ont rafalé nom
du chaudron rafale comme je l'annonçais
en préambule de ce reportage était
victime du correcteur automatique la
suite de notre dossier sur ces femmes
qui ont marqué l'histoire des yvelines
est dès demain dans le journal
dans l'actualité prochaine du territoire
aussi le 22e printemps des poètes qui
débute le 3 mars rendez vous culturel
incontournable à saint quentin en
yvelines avec une programmation riche
samedi à la commanderie un atelier
préparer à l'une des animations c'est le
bal à bla bla mathilde et demi elle a
suivi le récit de mélanie poker ils vous
inviteront à entrer dans la danse celle
des mots celle des gestes ils ouvriront
le bal à bla bla du printemps des poètes
n'y a pas vraiment de difficultés après
c'est plus la découverte de la matière
écrit tu vois là et essayer d'imaginer
un autre univers qui pourrait à la fois
être complémentaires mais en même temps
si ouvrir de ne pas refermer le texte
sur soi-même en fait pour être dans la
narration constante six danseurs
amateurs participent à cet atelier
depuis le mois de janvier
le fait de le de lancer le bal par un
petit un petit ou un grand groupe de
danseuses et danseurs c'est ça va aider
les tous les spectateurs du moment
vraiment du mal à se lancer en piste
je suis très intéressé par tout ce qui
est expression artistique sous toutes
ses formes
et voilà je trouvais ça très beau de
mêlée de formes d'expression donc le
geste et le mot elle les participants
évoluent sur des textes choisis par les
itinéraires poétique
ce 22e printemps des poètes est
consacrée cette année à la francophonie
même si on les prête pas exactement sur
le texte on verra c'est de la danse sur
des textes dits par des comédiens
véronique ellena malvoisin et benoît
lepecquet et ils sont ils auront à
ouvrir le bal
voilà le bal à bla bla et ensuite invité
les gens à entrer dans le bal pour la
suite pour toute la soirée pour ses
danseurs ce week-end était la dernière
préparation
le rendez vous est donné pour le 21 mars
au scarabée de la verrière dans un
instant sur tv 78 nouveau numéro du 7-8
culture avec à la présentation comme
chaque mardi soir aurélie 11 bonsoir
alors qu'à l'est nous qu'allez vous nous
proposer ce soir ou au menu de votre
émission
alors tout d'abord un rendez vous un
rendez vous pour les amoureux du métal
puisque les 6 et 7 mars sera la neuvième
édition du festival métal sfeir s'est
organisée par l'association met ta sauce
l'occasion de découvrir des styles
alternative dans deux lieux la salle de
la torah voisins le bretonneux et la
batterie de guyancourt nous assisterons
également à une première ce fut une
première ce soir au théâtre montansier à
versailles avec la maison de dos c'est
la toute dernière création d' hervé van
der meulen une pièce drôle sarcastique
et absurdes sur scène quinze comédiens
qui interprètent plus de 50 rôle et nous
avons pu justement assister à la
répétition générale et puis à partir du
28 février le cinéma est à l'honneur
dans les yvelines et le vexin c'est la
neuvième édition du festival des images
vagabonde
cela débutera d'ailleurs au ciné cette à
elancourt
le principe est bien dans une vingtaine
de lieux yvelinois 160 films sont en
compétition autour d'une thématique
femme rebelle tout un programme
merci aurélie le 7-8 culture à retrouver
dans quelques minutes sur tv 78 c'est la
fin de ce journal merci de votre
fidélité et belle soirée à tous sur tv
[Musique]